The Joe Rogan experience.
What the fuck man?
We're weird.
So weird.
What a stupid culture.
What are you doing?
I can't stop thinking about the guy.
The farted at the sink.
The airport.
We talked about it for
10 minutes afterwards.
Dudes fart when they go to the bathroom.
Dudes are constantly far
to in public restrooms.
Yeah.
But we were at the sink and the dude was
washing his hands and he cut a monster
fart and I told Tommy
about it and I was like,
dude,
this guy,
he broke.
He broke the rule.
Yeah.
I walked out just before this happened.
I unfortunately missed the incident,
but you said it immediately and I was.
I kept wrapping my head around it and I
think what I've come to the conclusion
is that if you do that,
all I'm looking for is
for you to acknowledge it.
Yeah.
You need to say something.
I want you to say something about that
because I was thinking about how an old
guy one time farted next to me in like
on a tram in the airport and I was like,
Jesus,
he led a fucking pretty big fart.
And I looked at him and he goes,
snuck out of me.
I was like,
alright.
And I kind of took away.
Like
I was like,
well thank you for acknowledging
your fart right now.
Yeah.
This guy was just washing
his hands and he just.
The sink is not the year.
I don't think you'd get a pass there.
Yeah,
it was definitely who does that?
It was definitely a gray area.
There's definitely a greater people
fart all the time at the urinals.
That's so common.
Yeah.
I heard a lot of parts.
But if you get done zip up,
walk all the way around and wash your
hands in the middle of Washington,
you just unload and no one said a word.
Yeah.
Everyone just just let it go.
And then we got outside.
I was like,
Yo Dude,
how do you feel about this?
I can't stop thinking about it.
And then we're trying to figure out what
kind of farts girls cut when they're in
the bathroom and whether or not they
wash their hands before nine each other.
Probably not as much.
Not as much,
but they definitely drop
heat in there for sure.
Once they close that door or
then they allow themselves.
Yeah,
they allow themselves
to fucking farted up.
You know,
there was a time when it was,
I want to say it was like my leg
was like 23 I guess.
And um,
uh,
there was this girl and I'm
like,
we've been seeing this story.
She like,
we had this thing like it
was this kind of like a fair,
if you will.
She was engaged and,
and so like it was hot and heavy.
It was fun.
But it was a girl.
It was,
yeah.
We had a good time and it was
one of those things where,
you know,
she would tell me,
she's like,
you know,
you're not gay this,
you're doing this too.
Well then you're playing with my heart.
And so it was Kinda like
dangerous at the same time.
And then her fiance found out,
her fiance actually found out when I
was going down on her and her bedroom.
He walked in.
No,
he was knocking on the door
outside and the lights went out.
We were like,
oh,
and he was like,
Hey,
I'm here.
I'm here,
open the door,
the door,
and immediately what do I do?
I'm like,
what do I do?
What do I,
I jump in the shower like an asshole
because that's not suspicious.
I just came over to shower.
You turn it on,
you turn the shower on the shower on.
And he's like,
what are you doing?
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I'll see you later if that was great.
Thanks for the study break and the shower.
I to get it off my face,
right?
Yeah,
I really did.
That's the thing with a steel wool pad,
you know,
God.
So when,
so,
and then,
and then she moved away and then um,
I got this phone call.
Oh God,
it was so crazy.
Um,
I got this phone call from
him to the fiance will do,
jerking off over the phone.
No,
he was mad.
He was like,
oh dude.
so what the fuck am I hearing
about this and this and this?
And she's in the background
and she's just like,
he's lying.
He's lying,
he's a,
he's a fucking faggot.
Don't listen to them that a year.
Oh yeah.
She threw you down down under the
bus and that was the last time.
And this was somebody that I was like,
I,
we had like,
I thought we had something and when
she said that I was like later,
like I couldn't like that was it.
So you,
how old were you at the time?
I was 22 or 23.
You had already come out,
you'd come out and so when you were,
when you were her,
you told her that you were gay?
Yeah,
like everyone knew.
Like it was just one of those.
But then you get those girls were like,
I'm going to turn you.
And you're like,
oh,
I get it all the time.
You get it all the time
trying to turn you straight.
Yeah,
there's a lot of fear involved
in being in the actual.
Yeah.
Or wild
itself.
Yeah.
And they're,
they worry about stuff they
make up stuff to worry about.
I mean just to,
just to give them a way out.
And so that was,
that was,
that was true for me too.
I mean,
it was overwhelming for me.
I didn't go back in there in the mountains
for a 10 day solo right out of the
gate.
I went for like one night,
like I went on a scouting trip
and then stayed one night,
then came out and it was just kind
of baby steps into it because it's,
you know,
if you,
if you pull,
you know,
I don't know how many
people there are here in la,
but how many people have stayed out
overnight in the mountains by themself.
It's not going to be very many people.
I mean it's,
I dunno.
Five.
Yeah,
maybe.
I mean it's,
it's just not something
people do in this day and age.
And so it's because it's,
you know,
it's,
you're out of your comfort zone.
But if you can do that.
And that's,
I,
I became good at that.
And actually then I,
I,
I loved it.
I remember,
let's see,
it was a,
um,
let me think what,
I don't know,
whatever.
I can't remember the year,
but I killed a six by six bull elk by
myself and it was my best bowl and I got
out of the wilderness,
has little Toyota four wheel drive.
I had this,
this bowl loaded up and
I was just so pumped.
Finally got cell service out on
the highway and I'm driving home.
And uh,
I called my wife and I was like,
I was like,
hey trace,
I killed a six by six bowl and she's like,
Princess di died.
I'm like,
what?
She's like,
Princess Di died.
I go,
who cares?
Killed a six by six bull.
It was just like you are.
So you know,
to everybody else,
Princess Diana,
Diane was like,
you know,
the world's going to stop,
but when you're back in the wilderness
and you killed a six by six bull elk,
nothing else matters.
And that's,
I just remembered.
That's the difference between living back
there where it's just about am I going
to find a place to sleep tonight?
Am I going to be warm and we'll have food?
That's it.
That's all you care about.
Yeah.
And um,
my parents actually didn't want me
to do martial arts because they were
terrified that I was going to become this
angry kid who knew how to fuck people
up.
Whereas before it was just angry
kid who really couldn't do anything.
It wasn't,
wasn't dangerous.
I was 11,
you know,
and then this 11 year old became
12 and the 12 year olds like,
ah,
I don't want to be like
Bruce Lee and the fuck,
you know,
I don't think so.
No.
He didn't want me to.
Evan didn't chucks.
I had noon shocks all the time.
People are just taking shit away from me.
I'd make him in the woodshop.
I would tell them that I was making
a chair legs fucking my chair.
Scrub two broken legs.
Funny that they look exactly like chuck's
Mr Jason,
who is the every kid loved nunchucks.
Everybody did.
Of course the Bruce Lee movies.
Man there were dope.
See Him swinging around us.
I had a really funny
story that happened there.
So there was a kid,
I was like seven.
And as a kid,
neighbor kid who was 12 and he was big
way bigger than me and he would kind of
pick on me a little bit
just because he was bigger,
but I had a bunch of older brothers so
they would always keep them in line or
whatever.
One day he did something
fucked up to me again.
That's seven versus 12.
So they're like,
alright,
we got a plan and I had,
you know,
those foam nunchucks that you could get,
like playing around.
They had a hard center
and foam on the outside.
So I had those hidden behind my back
and my brother was holding me back and
says,
Ryan,
go take your shots man.
I'm fucking sick cows kristen.
I'm sick of Chris's bullshit.
Go take your shots.
And meanwhile he's holding me loosely
and I just have these nunchucks and this
guy's like,
yeah,
I'm going to get them in cheap shots.
It goes up to punch me in the stomach.
And I just put them out like Bruce Lee
and just go ape shit on this 12 year old
kid.
And I remember I was like,
I am fucking Bruce.
Yeah,
I fucked up.
They were hitting him that it
was like a fucking swarm of bees.
He just read into.
It's funny.
I set them up.
What a dumb ass.
Yeah.
I'm holding my brother back.
Come Punch them.
Yeah.
What kind of an asshole believes that?
The kid deserves it.
He deserves it.
Just as a lesson,
the universe toggle.
What are you fucking stupid.
It's not going to hold his brother
and let him let you punch him.
Silly Bitch.